um here's stenny Hoyer and you know
what's funny about this because me and
Cliff Cliff was on the show yesterday
and we talked about this clip and I I
knew Cliff would have some good Insight
on this because he's been on the hill
before and he's someone who you know
probably watches a lot of floor debate
especially when it gets heated and it's
important so you know if you watch it
enough and c-span's boring as [__] right
it's like watching [__] paint dry
most of the time but if you watch it for
I don't know just a little bit you just
watch the debate happen when it's normal
boring stuff you would figure out oh
that's how it goes like this is the
order this is how why you have to
address the speaker whoever is presiding
even if it's a substitute presiding you
know that there's time and you have to
give time and yield time back and all
kinds of weird stuff that doesn't happen
in everyday life but it happens in an
official proceeding but stenny Hoyer
here actually is caught off guard that
he [__] stumped her so badly because
I don't think he intended to do this
this is I mean it was just a simple
question right well let's let's watch
let's watch and I asked the gentle lady
to yield for a
question's recognized it's not my time I
ask you to yield I have reserved you're
free to speak yes I'm asking if you you
for
question so Lauren bobert In This Moment
clearly does not understand that stenny
oror has to address the speaker whenever
you're whenever you're in the house
chamber or the Senate chamber you have
to address it is procedure that you have
to address the speaker that's why when
they're in that's why they're when
they're in the house chamber and they're
addressing they say Mr Speaker or Mrs
speaker yeah that's or if they're in the
Senate they say Mr President or Mrs
president they're not talking to the
president of United States they're
talking to the president of the
Senate but Lauren Bard apparently has
been on the capital here for three
[__] years and still doesn't know
this and that stenny hoer if he's gonna
ask her a question in procedure to
address her he has to get permission on
the house floor from the person who
controls the time to ask the question to
her not to the speaker but stenny orer
here obviously doesn't understand that
she's a [__] Mega bonehead and
doesn't understand this but he keeps
going watch this sure ask your question
what funds in this bill are used for the
purposes you uh okay are opposed
to
sorry I couldn't hear oh oh I'm sorry I
couldn't hear you U because of my
stupidity I I really um my stupid you
did not yeah and I love sorry I didn't
hear what he said you heard what he
asked you you knew the question and
here's the thing you got [__]
busted he stumped you and it was a basic
question which is like where are these
funds that you're talking about and then
she goes on to say as well watch she
like oh it's precautionary what the [__]
are you talking about well here let's
let's watch what she says which is
ridiculous and he stumps her here again
gentlemen I was getting clarification
this is
precautionary precautionary for
what he's honestly like what wa what
what what's hilarious is is that her
staffer now and let me show you here
okay her staffer is sitting behind her
here this is her staffer now this is the
idiot that works for the idiot because
this idiot doesn't even know what
precautionary means um she's telling her
that it's just say it's precautionary
she's like okay that sounds that sounds
really official that sounds really
[__] smart actually so that's what
I'm gonna say I'm gonna say that's
precautionary let's see how it works out
yes I understand I understand what are
that are in place that are allowing The
Refuge of illegal aliens in these cities
and there is an influx in crime and
drugs I understand in these cities and
there's no there's no way for these
folks to even report what is taking
place because you know what's funny is
if you look at these two faces they're
like yeah we're totally owning him like
he's totally getting know here she's
like yeah we got you because those Libs
in their Democratic cities are alling
these illegals to come in watch what
stin oror is they're protected under
this fake policy that has been created
that is subduing the actual rule of law
that we have in the Constitution of the
United States no no not the
Constitution but what you said is none
of the funds in this bill can be spent
for that objective and that is
precautionary I want what funds are in
this bill to be spent for that objective
I I have seen this Administration use
all sorts of funds none that's what she
actually means none now to understand
exactly what is happening here is this
is an appropriation hearing and this is
an appropriation debate and she's she is
putting on the floor an amendment to
make sure that spending our our money
isn't spent in this way and he's like
it's not spent in this way so what the
[__] are you talking about why are you
introducing an amendment to not spend
funds that aren't spent that way anyways
what the [__] are you talking about this
is like putting a Band-Aid where you
don't have a boo boo what are you
talking about like you're just wearing a
Band-Aid okay Nelly with the Band-Aid on
your face you don't actually have a boo
boo you're just wearing the Band-Aid
just to be cool and hey man it was cool
it was cool it was you're right it was
for